because Arizona shares a nearly 400 mile
border with Mexico immigration is a
hot-button issue there in that state CBS
news political correspondent ed O'Keefe
spoke to four Arizona voters this week
about immigration for Face the Nation
you see those images of families
separated along the border you've seen
the images of young children being taken
away from their parents when you see
those get published in the newspapers or
see them on TV when you see those images
what do you think you know obviously
it's it's it's terrible to see a child
whipped away from their parents or vice
versa but I think that you need to
recognize that these images are being
printed to produce some type of visceral
emotion and so my opinion would always
be to obviously take it and analyze it
and then see the actual factual basis
behind it I would hope that those images
have the purpose of creating action on
my end I just certainly don't think that
the images are doctored so you think the
guys like me yep or the organization's I
work for are publishing or distributing
these images to advance an agenda not to
allow you to seem possible it factually
happened yeah so I think that it's
possible I - so in saying that CBS or
any other major Broadcasting System
would do it but I think that you know
things like that are possible to print
things to align potential viewers or
readers or listeners towards a certain
way well I think everybody went down
there and agreed that it should cease do
you think this would have been addressed
as quickly as it was by the president if
the images hadn't been published or
broadcast on television it possibly you
know they brought it brought it - you
know and to a greater sent and what it
you know they really went overboard with
bringing that that out everybody saw it
so you think you think broadcasting
those images publishing those photos
wasn't was was the media going overboard
up to a certain extent the way you agree
I want to keep showing them
yeah it's something we need to face as
Americans we don't treat children like
that we don't treat people that enter
our country like that well if the police
arrest a person or a family for some
crime and they have children seeking
asylum isn't a crime and then they can't
from their countries and send another
feature online or some not in crime they
don't put them in cages they should keep
showing the images because we still
don't have a solution even after the
executive order was signed yesterday so
as far as we're concerned those children
whose images we saw that were in cages
are still in those cages because they
haven't been reunited with their
families you can see all of its
discussion tomorrow morning on Face the
Nation right here on CBS